okay so Sheldon proposed to Amy every
saw no thanks to me what was the mood
like on set during that moment I
remember coming down
I take Polaroids on set so we must have
what do you think hundreds Polaroid's at
this point that are all up on our little
wall of shame in the wardrobe room so
obviously I went up to get my camera for
this moment I knew we're going to do and
I had to get the photograph on my floor
ID and I came down and basically
everyone and everyone's mother and
friend was behind the camera for this
one scene even though we all knew it was
going to happen but and I started crying
like I really we were all like we're all
trying we're all crying watching him
good I came as close to crying as I'm
capable of then almost cried yes know
what's really cool do you see so many
years and so many relationships you know
have transformed and to see that you
know be this pinnacle this season it was
just really cool and we've all just come
a long way and it just it just made me
we were all kind of crying behind them
so far every story has to do with Kaylee
crying yeah again yes and other crimes
that one was a month oh no you guys have
all worked together for quite some time
most of these writers have been there
for the whole run of the show but they
actually have some questions they wanted
the writers have some questions they
wanted me to ask the cast if that's okay
so Eric Kaplan wave Eric Kaplan would
like to know do the actors change in
front of each other that's a yes you're
taking two one oh I'm sorry we have
though yeah I'm sure we have I I've seen
Simon try to wiggle into his pants yeah
much more than I'd like to admit that
was really tight pants yeah yeah and he
still fits into them ten years later
same size Devo he's got a great bottom
goin away
unbelievable manages their two kids no
less yeah it is funny though you know we
we rarely miss time on the show I don't
think any of us have ever missed more
than one or two days on the show but I
remember once I had to miss four
and I came back and Johnny send me a
picture because he took his pants off
and sat on my couch yeah so that's as
close as I got to sing him naked if you
guys are interested I had that picture
on my phone if you see me on the floor
I'll show it to you
[Laughter]
lucky you this is a question from Maria
Ferrari say Lemuria the question is
would the actors be friends with the
writers in real life no you wouldn't why
are you lying
[Laughter]
[Music]
would you which one were you
who wouldn't you be friends with just
list that I'm saying okay I'm like that
why would duh no idea friends with all
of you guys yeah yes they're hilarious
yeah good nice guy Anna if you hanging
out this is actually I have to say this
is often on shows a bit of a chasm
between the stage and the writers room
and that's certainly not the case on
this show it's all we're all very very
very close and share of love for the
shared goal that we all have to make the
show the best we can be hey I'm dark
marina you have a fun friend story about
kevin sussman don't you Kevin I do not
know if you remember this uh but once I
saw you out in the world we were like
going to the moth and it seemed like
maybe you were on a date and I was like
oh it's Kevin from work I'm gonna go say
hi and you kind of pulled up and I don't
know I I kind of got the vibe that maybe
it was like oh shoot here's a fan
interrupting me no did he just find
something for you and walk away he just
pulled out his headshot
Kevin carries several signed headshot
yeah yeah a by Jack yeah he knows
because I handed you an eight-by-ten
doesn't aim that I didn't no no I it's
more likely that I just didn't know your
name so I awkward 'no scam off and you
know i didn't know who you are
wait when will you want to date
this is a long time ago by the way I'm
sorry your rebuttal to the story that
you didn't recognize Maria is that you
didn't recognize Maria yeah but I but
but no I recognized her I just I just I
don't think I remembered you know her
name and the crate and that's not that
Gracie gives away it was a long time ago
you know the crazier thing is all the
people that I've been working with for
ten years that I still don't remember
there there is the on on stage 25 at
Warner Brothers and they're on the back
wall there are Polaroids of everybody
who works there with their name yes and
I study that like every week and what a
job wedding right very nervous I have
the mind of a spaghetti strainer you
know if I don't see you moments after I
look at the chart but this by the way I
recommend this for everybody's job
because you're on the stage and there
are people that you've worked with for
like seven or eight years Bill and Bill
and it's hard to go bill but I know your
name that's where this is headed I know
your name we should start lining people
up for questions I imagine there's mics
posted out there right yeah ask us some
questions guys well-sewn be a tie and
we'll throw to you guys in a moment but
let's just sort of orderly fashion kind
of come up to the mics and line up and
we'll we'll try to get to everybody but
we won't get to everybody but in the
meantime we have a question for Kunal
you had one of the sexiest moments of
the season in the hot tub with Kevin
Sussman what was that like yeah what was
it like yeah what is it was a it was a
little disgusting but not because of God
because of Kevin because Kevin was the
best part of the hot tub it's a you know
it is the hot tub was slightly dirty and
you clean it and you know hot tubs
should be nice and bubbly and dark this
had lights underneath so you could see
every layer at Kane
and we were in there for quite a while
shooting so a skin was like wrinkly and
falling off and the water was at feet
kept touching my garlic balance and so I
like a leg to touch and then we'd act
like it didn't it was quite awkward ah
it was not Senegal Oh ever discuss this
this VI
had I known I wouldn't have been so
flippy I liked one of your biggest
complaints is the day you spent at work
in a hot tub not a lot of people good
yeah thanks it is the circumstances yeah
I don't like putting my head under water
ever oh yeah yeah yeah a bunch of people
had to coach me and you know it's going
to be okay we have a lot of people
around in like two feet of water but you
know I I do the you know when I swim
it's it's that's what's way more of a
survival stroke so just having to have
my head under water and I don't say it
wasn't horrifying it was it was funny
when it got sexy when you're choosing
each other like so tell me have you been
like that was the kind of fun part you
know because it felt like just two dudes
hanging out on a hot tub what's the big
deal yeah at work yeah let's let's go to
the audience I can't see but where who's
this oh thank you oh my god
[Applause]
Wow you look incredible
why thank you what is your question um
first of all my name is the button lady
they know they've seen me before
um why do they call Ghana I'm sorry what
why did they call you that never mind we
can talk later go ahead um first of all
thank you for coming back to comic-con
we've missed you
oh thank you guys thank you for coming
out and I work with kids with special
needs speechless is an amazing show
thank you so much oh oh thank you I mean
speechless it's on Wednesdays at ABC on
a 30 yes number two on the call sheet
that one what seed your carpet yeah yeah
got it okay a lot of it my question
because other people want to do
my question is penny have you ever
thought of the last name for yourself
since none of us know your maiden name I
have it in my head what I think that it
is virgins but now I'm penny Hofstetter
so it doesn't matter just think she's
cher doesn't have a last name this one
named Ariel need a last name am I made
oh the Merv yeah sorry go ahead
spider-man thank your partner entire way
morning voting hakuna since you and I
both went to Temple University yeah
what was your journey after graduating
to getting your work started in acting
and getting on this show uh I've made a
terrorist on NCIS
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then I booked the Big Bang Theory
that is amazing so my range is
incredible my question is which has been
your favorite episode of the entire
seasons and so hard I'm still I'm glad I
wasn't a part of that that's a difficult
question I still like the the I almost
said Easter egg hunt was not an Easter
egg hunt
Gavin John yes that was so times we all
were a lot of us are part it just was
really funny I like when we're all doing
things together it's very physical it
just always makes me laugh and I got to
push Melissa pushed me over it was just
she's wickedly strong it was fun I like
when we have this big group episode I
like that when the three guys got high
in the desert yeah
really funny I got to make fun of
Simon's axe about Johnny's act for the
American accent I got to make fun of it
for once which was really fun and what
does that sound like yeah
what do it everything you sounds
everything you say sounds so stupid in
American stars are pretty aren't they
yes I was funny when it's funny when
he's like Raj the world is spinning
spinning too fast
make it stop make it stop and I'm like
that whole like monologue about rabbit
about being a king of rabbits and I want
to hear more of your American accent
what I want to hear more of your
American accent you want to hear more of
my America neck I wish Simon was Joe
because then he'd just make fun of me in
my India neck okay this is a question
from Bill Brady for the cast what or
well actually for the writers to what
famous guests are generated a fanboy
fangirl moment what Oh Bob Newhart for
me certainly
oh I know what famous guest star baby
III when I I have an answer if I know
Kevin he has several I'll try to keep it
brief um when I first came on the show
one of the earlier seasons I met Wil
Wheaton who I had been a fan of and I
was you know I try not to get starstruck
and stuff and I tried to play it off all
cool and he immediately he's so nice he
made me feel super comfortable like
within minutes of meeting him he was
teaching me a card game Queen's necklace
and it was great and I was like oh yeah
okay he's just a person we're all just
people and then years later when Adam
West was on set yeah this is that's Wil
Wheaton the whole time he was talking
about how amazing it because he's a huge
Adam West fan and he's talking about how
awesome it is to be in the same room and
it wasn't till like late in the week
that I happened to be standing there
when he sort of locked over to Adam West
all super nervous and and he did the
thing that I did to him to Adam West you
know mr. West I just I didn't want to
bother you but I don't will mister
weaken the first time you miss to eat oh
wait you don't hog him wait I'm the only
one he makes called mr. Wheaton did it
you guys remember to show the Wonder
Years
I remember when I first went because I
got to make out with Danica McKellar on
the show oh yeah and I remember my when
I was growing up in New Delhi I had my
first kiss in in in eighth grade and I
didn't know what I was doing and I
closed my eyes and I remembered the
first time that Winnie and Kevin kissed
on the park bench I said just pretend
like you're doing that and then in real
life I mean in life on Big Bang Theory
life I actually got to kiss Winnie I
mean Danica McKellar in real life and
that was a story that came full circle
nine months later she was pregnant
that is a fact by me but that's just a
fact writers obviously have some - right
yeah who is your fangirl fanboy moments
from the writers I don't add unless was
it was a remarkable thing because and I
got I made him call me old chum but but
there was there was a day that I had
spoken to
Wil Wheaton in the morning and then it
was the same day we were talking to
Leonard Nimoy about coming and doing the
voice
and he he called on the phone and I
talked to him on the phone and then I
talked later in the day to levar burton
who was calling to try to get a clip or
something of show he done and I said
levar if I could go back in time and
tell my younger self that there's a day
in my life when I talked to Wesley
Crusher and mr. Spock and Geordi LaForge
I would have died and never made it is a
time paradox and I have a really good
Adam West story so he was on our 200th
episode and after our table read he
called me over he had some questions
about the script and he had a line the
script where he told I think Leonard and
Koothrappali don't ring my doorbell or
my poodle's will go crazy and Adam said
to me do you think I could have a
tougher dog like a like a Rottweiler and
I said well mr. what I mean you could
but I don't think it says funny
and he said well I have poodles in real
life so I guess it's fine that is
hysterical what about you guys what was
my favorite for me that one we've had
lots of great ones but meeting James
Earl Jones and having him on set for the
week was amazing and getting to hear
words we wrote delivered in that voice
when he gets to say I like Star Wars to
was what fantastic and Carrie Fisher was
in that episode as well yeah and which
this was surprising but they met for the
first time on our set they had never met
before I came out to bed dad and they
hugged and that was the first time I met
Wow I don't know I think I have to say
Stanley because he was so cool room and
such a stud he really was like oh my god
he got so much swagger even range Oh
Stephen Hawking oh my god Stephen
Hawking came you know it was we didn't
we shot the Stephen Hawking scene in his
office with with Jim so the rest of the
actors weren't there but Stephen Hawking
came and watched a run-through of our
show yeah and watching Simon do the
Stephen Hawking voice while Stephen
Hawking is watching the run-through was
pretty incredible
they loved it there's remember Kayle
Kayle had the line of yeah I'll never
forget somebody says do you know Stephen
Hawking is you remember your line back
the guy in the wheelchair is the
wheelchair dude who invented time yeah
and we're doing the run-through and mr.
Hawking is literally right here just in
my eyeline as I'm saying this Chuck and
I said it I just look to him like he was
laughing he loved it he loved being
there you amazing yeah awesome we've had
some amazing people on the lucky lucky
Christopher Lloyd critical he was
incredible I don't think I've ever
laughed so hard than that scene no one
could keep a straight face oh my god
because we didn't know what he was gonna
do what about love he had always said
something different was Bach
Bob Newhart was a remark you know yeah
it's you know especially for those of us
who grew up watching me right into and
to come on the show and then there there
was a there was a point where somebody
was giving the director was giving Bob a
note and he said well maybe you could do
that
Newhart stutter here on this line and
Bob Newhart said I I don't stutter i
stammer do you know the difference and
our director said no and Bob Newhart
said a house in Bel Air
[Laughter]
also Billy Bob Thornton was oh he was
ready Bob Thornton I can't believe some
of these people yeah you think about it
it's amazing my question is I know you
guys have been playing these same
characters for about 10 years and I just
wanted to know which character would you
like to switch to besides yes and like
in a future oh that's a great question
yeah I like to switch with cinnamon the
dog Richard cinnamon you in a minute all
day on Wales what ice I always get the
cutest outfits I mean let's be honest
that'd be fun I'm just saying it'd be
nice to not wear four layers under
system yeah I know I got four layers of
oh it's freezing yeah but I mean be nice
to a some shorts and a tank top for once
on the show you know the wardrobe room
has this incredibly depressing shelf
that is just like 25 sweater vests yes
all stacked up in a rural injured with
Raj on top of it breaks my heart no
matter what the weather is brown yeah
well what else would I want to trade
with another actor I wouldn't mind
taking a shot at Wolowitz I mean you
know tired of being the third wheel want
to be the man in the house hardest thing
is that kind of suggests that you think
you could do a better job and then you
know certainly I but I always thought
Kevin would make a great Leonard do
everything to make a good Leonard yeah
yeah thank you thanks thank thanks mom
what am i meeting you at the car at 5:00
John Johnny do you remember when we were
very in the very first conversations
about this that there was a you were
there was a chuckle approached you about
Sheldon and you said no that you
preferred Leonard there right yeah
but I hadn't met Kevin at the time I may
have pitched heaven forever yes that is
true I wanted I was I wanted to be part
of the Leonard penny love story
even before Kaylee was cast and then
only time not all that we were different
we have a very special treat for for
this the the end of our panel Steve why
don't you you set us up for for this
rather participatory moment we're going
to have sure so sometimes we write and
shoot things that we love but they don't
make it on TV so one thing from this
season that you never got to hear was
Amy singing an alternate version of soft
kitty to Sheldon so I thought we could
end things here maybe with a sing-along
if you guys would help us out we're
going to put the words on the screen for
the never-before-seen version of soft
kitty about other animals so well it
starts with soft kitty and then there's
there's two more animals after that if
you'll help us out maybe with the cast
start us off yeah
who is a pseudonym I know I'll get rid
all right buddy
I merely put your hearts into hard turn
here we go justice that photogate once
again that's for the heart to do this
one what long time lets you to turn me
one more time but everyone sing at the
top of your lungs okay there we go one
two three we love you guys
[Applause]
you